- Okay, Jesse, for all
those "Bachelor" fans,
what do we have to look forward to?
- Is Clayton gonna end up with his person
or is it all gonna fall apart?
- I do sense a cliffhanger.
Is it all gonna just blow up
and nobody's gonna get that final rose?
- That's the crazy part.
We actually still don't
know what's going to happen.
- You don't have to tell me
who, if it was up to you,
that you would pick for Clayton?
- I'm like telling him.
- And is he listening?
- It's selective hearing.
- Mm hmm.
And do the fans have a favorite?
- I think honestly right now
it's really up in the air.
I think it could be Rachel
or it could be Gabby.
- Well, as they say in the
song, it's the final countdown.
Thank you, Jesse.
(beep)
Who's gonna get that rose?
(laughing)